este miércoles se cumple el cuarto día
de una intensa persecución en canadá de
uno de los dos hermanos sospechosos de
una cadena de apuñalamientos en la zona
de james smith screen nation mientras
que damián anderson fue encontrado
muerto el lunes el paradero de su
hermano myles sigue siendo desconocido y
los residentes de la reserva indígena
están preocupados por su seguridad
no sé si nuestras vidas serán las mismas
para el sporting grace
apenas he dormido en dos días porque me
aterra que pueda volver y elegir a otra
persona al azar y hacerlo de nuevo
el martes tras los informes de
avistamiento de sanderson las
autoridades instaron a la gente a
permanecer en el interior aunque la
gendarmería canadiense confirmó
posteriormente que el sospechoso no se
encontraba en la comunidad el primer
ministro del país ha instado a la
precaución se mejor es importante que
todo el mundo siga las instrucciones de
las autoridades locales el gobierno
federal está trabajando estrechamente
con los líderes de la comunidad y con la
provincia de herat tenemos que
asegurarnos de que todo el mundo se
mantiene a salvo de que resolvemos esto
lo más rápidamente posible es fútbol los
atentados han conmocionado al país y son
uno de los más mortíferos de su historia
el pasado criminal de sanderson es
amplio figuran 59 condenas penales a lo
largo de varios años y las autoridades
canadienses han reiterado sus
llamamientos a cualquier información que
pueda alertar sobre su localización